hi guys hi guys hey I'm hiding up here
you're hiding down here ah my can see
every chamber and I'm Cody Melcher and
this is Tara Jessa and Cody also just
saw two as well oh we just got cars
three twat person was great cars too can
just jump off a flippin cliff it's a hot
garbage fire no it's got a good Pixar
doesn't live up to know it's a hot
garbage fire I'm sorry I'm gonna stick
with that okay great there's the boss
baby effect though
and this just redeemed the crap right I
think we need to mention cars too
because cars three of the lot of what
car three did right is what cars to did
wrong
making the comedic side kick the main
character completely getting rid of the
basic main character losing the heart of
the main character a whole not
understanding of what made the first
movie important car sir II could have
gone straight from cars ones yes and you
would have missed absolutely nothing
right heart she was not entertaining it
was like he said low-hanging fruit it
was very like everyone was a stereotype
it just wasn't entertaining this I went
in two cars three expecting cars to and
cars three was alright yeah well in car
three was about the same thing that
things that cars was about because we're
gonna have some in our car it is that
cars to felt like a spinoff not a sequel
because like I said was about mater yeah
it's right right like they've got that
new frozen one coming out and that and
it's and it's called Olaf frozen
adventure a thing it's like that cartoon
was mater's cars adventure right
overseas for majors overseas yeah it's
like barely lightning McQueen's in it
all and it's like and this movie is
about the same characters and core
concepts from cars one also real quick
while I'm remembering it the short to be
four cars three oh my God thank you for
remembering
that's the thing I mentioned on stage
sometimes that bullies don't have like
children bullies don't have movies for
them what actually makes eyes they're
always villainized yeah you know and
this was a movie about so short I felt I
felt we could we were like we would over
a journey gorgeous but this was about a
bully who changes his ways in effect but
he's the hero he becomes the he is the
protagonist he starts to bully and he
you know you either you either live long
enough to stay as a bully or a bunch of
clothing changes your life I mean every
time if you haven't seen cars - there is
the brief overview of of the doc
character who passed away from old age
but they don't talk about it at all they
don't have a sauce expire yeah um cool
bye I guess gluten great um they really
do a giant tribute to him and she's a
great character and he loves oh he's my
favorite character the first time yeah
absolutely
I cast mold of them McQueen's trainer
like he's a big part of it and so they
really bring him back in three and it
feels really nice and you finally get
the closure that you want in this
animated car I love the in the third
movie doc is still like the most badass
character they show like some clips of
his early racing day and you're like
hell yeah you're like third movie you've
been gone for two films you're still the
most badass character that's cool that's
really exciting
good for you and then they really bring
it in with the new characters that they
introduced with it which is Cruz who I
just flippin love I leaned over to Cody
during yourself when I was like who knew
cars 3 was going to be the feminist film
of the year yeah it was very
I felt I felt empowered it was really
fitting I mean on top of her they also
introduced a bunch of other really cool
characters that I felt equally like
connected to like the old all the
Alzheimer's but especially the one who
stole her number uh the woman who's the
the demolition derby bus like they had a
lot of really cool dynamic interesting
characters and all right and and they
were all really well-written
they weren't just throw away hair Jers
they all had their moments as little as
they were like they all all came back at
the end
and when crews did her thing and yeah
they all has their own they had their
own purpose
individual of the plot didn't they also
contributed the plot very well so
nothing felt like terribly contrived
everything everything fit really well it
was a really cool just put together dude
it was the writing wasn't good and I
really enjoyed how like we were saying
cars to didn't have lightning lightning
queen at all he was just like this such
a two-dimensional character yeah and
this one really brought him back in in a
good way and then introduced crews and
they had such a good relationship comes
the point where a butcher glad they
didn't do thank God that was it I was
worried about what you're going to say
yes the rural romance aspect of it it
may would have made them yeah and I'm so
glad they didn't and they do a great
friendship and he says his girlfriend it
was not that works so much are we
actually we do uh we Google's uh cars
for hit what happens hahaha there is a
seam there's a scene in cars three where
they like it's like flashbacks to like
Dokken and lightning and I leaned over
to Tara and I was like gay and like it
didn't worry it's very Greek if you know
what I mean
and uh so I was like you know what I
gotta look it up so when we got back
here I had my Google Doc Hudson
Lightning McQueen porn and then we just
ended up in a world of cars porn my
favorite one I think our favorite one I
can say is which cars is it mater its
mater mater is uh is having carnal
relations with Garfield the cat hmm and
the blog is called I hate mondays yeah
cameras scarred for life that stuff i
i've seen all that that's i know just so
hard for me to get Owen Wilson's face
out of my green I would ya watching this
film Alan Wilson is still kind of weird
Troy he works but it still sounds like
it's such a weird choice yeah
but that's the other weird thing about
cars three is that they bring back a lot
of characters from cars one that we
didn't see at all in cars to everyday
like all the radiators brings people
chick all these texts all of these girls
that are completely gone - yeah
Mack yeah yeah all completely not in
charge - so they're all back in cars
three it's like they completely tried to
retcon cards - as best they could I mean
it's like people love cars so hard and
then cars - was more of like a excuse
for me the fun spin-off but like not
many people see it'll be done after that
and then didn't it was like we're going
to make a whole world with cars and
we're just like gonna keep this ball
rolling and they were like oh no we had
the whole thing do the whole thing we
had to do the whole damn thing but I'm
confused why Michael Keaton didn't
reprise chick because he's chicken the
first one I believe and I can only
imagine he got busy but also like how
chicken is that many lines you can go
into a studio for a day and probably
knock out with chicks line I would
probably sell cars - I mean like they
got the entire cast back other than Paul
Newman for reasons uh but everyone
Michael Keaton is like now after Birdman
I'm too cool like I'm sure roll line
yeah Birdman Superman I'm - everything
have you seen Birdman together with a
multiplicity for a minute race
multiplicity black points there's a baby
car how does that happen
oh it's my favorite car it's a great car
but how do baby cars does it card grow
up and do things her mother and default
image is a smart car I also get with a
child nothing's a child I think is with
your child I mean I think just smart
cars have a higher pitch smaller voice
hey this was via jail yeah so right top
three cards Rilke that's our final top
three cards go baby car baby car baby
car okay baby car cruise
um older girl car who was 94 or 92 or
was the one under McQueen is no where's
95 she was 94 then is that right cuz I
remember thinking why is she one under
him
weird that was my genetics vida okay
mine are doc uh I think Luigi is his
name the the people I love Luigi and the
mayor right pitstop meters yeah animator
yes as I've made her doc ah pissed on
mater mater mater mater mater mater
mater is gonna make mate mate mate
next week review transformers 5 100 who
knows I don't know guys
I'm gonna have to watch all of the
Transformers movies now I'm definitely
not doing that 100 percent not happen
I'm committed because of you I care so
I'm gonna do it but I'm not watching
them all in a row like I did with fast
and furious can you love those well the
family is important but um yeah my cars
and family visit me to the cars family
made it alright guys we'll see you next
week with transformers thank you so much
for watching
same camera time same currently no miss
your show I'm just here for the ride
thank you for being here alright bye oh
god I'm 25
classy business you know who else did a
classy dis mouth mr. food made
[Music]